D
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
WHILE, EVERYONE, IT IS CRUNCH
TIME.
ONLY SIX DAYS UNTIL CHRISTMAS,
AND MILLIONS OF PEOPLE ARE
SCRAMBLING TO GET THEIR LOVED
ONE SOME LAST MINUTE GIFTS.
JESSE HAS BEEN BUSY FIGHTING THE
WAR ON CHRISTMAS, SO WHO KNOWS
IF HE HAS HAD TIME.
ERIC HAS BEEN TRYING TO TRAIN
GUS.
HAROLD ORDERS HIS GUESTS LAST
YEAR BECAUSE HE IS NOT PREPARED,
AND IF KATIE RUNS OUT OF TIME,
SHE WILL JUST WANT FOR CHRISTMAS
DINNER ON HER WAY TO THE HOUSE.
♪ ♪
>> IT'S MINE!
MOVE IT!
♪ ♪
>> Dana: BUT NOW YOU CAN JUST
ORDER ANYTHING FROM THE COMFORT
OF YOUR COUCH APPEAR NEARLY 60%
OF SHOPPERS SAY THEY BOUGHT
PRESENCE ONLINE, BUT THIS LEADS
US TO A VERY SERIOUS QUESTION TO
KICK US OFF.
AS THE INTERNET TAKEN THE FUN
OUT OF CHRISTMAS?
HAROLD, IS IT NO FUN ANYMORE?
>> Harold: FIRST OF ALL, GLAD
TO BE BACK.
STEAM ON SO GLAD TO HAVE YOU.
>> Harold: NO, THE INTERNET
ALLOWS YOU TO KIND OF PINPOINT
AND BE PRECISE ABOUT WHAT YOU
WANT FOR SOMEBODY, BUT IT IS
HARD -- I FIND IT HARD TO
SHOP -- I STILL LIKE TO GO OUT,
NOT ONLY SEE THE DECORATIONS BUT
SEE THE STORES, SEE WHAT'S
AVAILABLE.
WHAT I HAVE LEARNED, DOING THAT,
IS THERE IS MORE AVAILABLE
ONLINE THEN IN THE STORES.
YOU REALLY CANNOT GET AS MANY
IDEAS.
I DO THINK THIS CHRISTMAS,
PEOPLE ARE HAPPY TO BE BACK
TOGETHER.
I THINK THE EXPERIENCE IS
PROBABLY MORE SO THAN -- AT
LEAST IN MY EXPERIENCE.
MY DAUGHTER'S BIRTHDAY IS
THURSDAY, SO SHE GETS A DOUBLE
WHAMMY.
THAT CHRISTMAS/BIRTHDAY THING.
SO I HOPE SHE LIKES WHAT I GOT
HER TODAY.
>> Greg: YOU JUST TOLD -- YOU
GOT HER BOOKS.
>> Harold: THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY TRUE.
>> Dana: KATIE, HAVE YOU GONE
UP SHOP IN?
>> Katie: I HAVE DONE BOTH.
I LOVE A GOOD TRIP TO T.J.MAXX
AND HOME GOODS ARE ALL THE
LITTLE STOCKING STUFFERS AND TO
DECORATE.
ALL THAT KIND OF THING.
HOWEVER, I AM ALSO A BIG FAN OF
ALLOWING PEOPLE TO SHOP FOR
THEMSELVES BECAUSE YOU NEVER
WANT TO BUY SOME I GET A GIFT
THAT THEY WANT TO RETURN.
GET THEM A GIFT CARD, THEY CAN
GET WHAT THEY WANT.
MAYBE YOU DON'T KNOW THE RIGHT
SIZE TO BUY.
ONLINE SHOPPING MAKES WRAPPING A
LOT EASIER.
THAT IS THE MOST STRESSFUL
THING.
BUT ALSO NOW A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
INTERESTED IN EXPERIENCES.
THAT DOES NOT TAKE A LOT OF
SHOPPING.
THAT TAKES MORE COORDINATION OF
SCHEDULE, WHICH CAN BE A LITTLE
STRESSFUL, BUT I STILL THINK
SHOPPING ONLINE IS FUN.
YOU'RE A MEDIUM?
GOOD TO KNOW.
I HAVE NOT GOTTEN YOUR GIFT.
I'M ON TOP OF IT.
>> Dana: WE HAVE THIS
AGREEMENT THAT WE WOULD ONLY BUY
THINGS FROM SMALL BUSINESS FOR
EACH OTHER, SO TO ME, THAT WAS
SHOPPING AT THE ACTUAL STORY.
WHAT?
>> Greg: IS JUST FUNNY BECAUSE
YOU ARE SMALL, SO IT WOULD MAKE
SENSE THAT THEY ARE SMALL
BUSINESSES.
>> Dana: MY SISTER DID IT
ENTIRELY ONLINE.
JESSE, HOW DID YOU SHOP?
>> Jesse: WE SHOP FOR THE KIDS
ONLINE BECAUSE THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S COMING, BUT THE WIFE, YOU
HAVE TO SHOP FOR IN PERSON
BECAUSE YOUR WIFE KNOWS WHEN
PACKAGES ARE ARRIVING.
THEY CAN SMELL IT.
YOU CAN SMELL IT.
ONCE HE GETS NEAR THE HOUSE,
IT'S LIKE THEY HAVE A SIXTH
SENSE, SO YOU HAVE TO RUN
INTERFERENCE.
YOU HAVE TO CUT THEM OFF BEFORE
IT GETS DELIVERED.
I AM A HANDS-ON GUY.
I LIKE TO STROKE THE CASHMERE.
FEEL IT.
TOUCH IT.
SMELL IT.
THAT'S HOW I DO MY SHOPPING.
MEN NEED HELP.
WE CANNOT JUST BLINDLY PUNCHED
BUTTONS AND HOPE THAT SOMETHING
COMES IN THE RIGHT SIZE FROM THE
INTERNET.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A STYLIST TELL
YOU WHAT YOU DO, WHAT THE GOOD
BRAND IS.
I DON'T KNOW SIZES.
CERTAIN SIZES FOR WOMEN ARE VERY
CONFUSING.
DIFFERENT SIZES IN THE YEAR SHOE
SIZES.
YOU DON'T WANT TO EVER GO TO BIG
BECAUSE THAT'S INSULTING.
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
BRAND YOU ARE GETTING.
THEN WOMEN KNOW WHAT WOMEN WANT,
SO YOU'RE IN THE RED ZONE.
MEN CAN ONLY GUESS WHAT WOMEN
WANT, AND CHRISTMAS IS NOT A
GUESSING GAME.
CHRISTMAS, YOU HAVE TO BE --
>> Dana: YOU WANT TO NEARLY.
>> Jesse: CHRISTMAS, YOU
BETTER NAIL IT.
I WENT INTO -- IT WAS SO
INTIMIDATING.
EVERYBODY HAD MORE MONEY THAN I
DID.
EVERYBODY WAS BETTER LOOKING.
AND I DON'T EXPERIENCE THAT A
LOT.
YOU SHOULD HAVE SEEN IT.
EVERYONE LOOKED LIKE A MODEL,
WALKING AROUND WITH CONFIDENCE.
OH, $4,000.
I WILL TAKE TWO.
I STARTED TO SWEAT.
YOU HAVE THAT'S WHY LIKE I
CANNOT AFFORD THIS?
AND THEN WE WENT TO SACKS, AND
THEY WRAPPED IT FOR ME.
THAT IS THE KEY.
>> Greg: YOUTHS IN MORE THAN
ONE.
THE ONE THING I MISS IS A DRUNK
MALL SHOPPING.
THAT'S WHAT I DID IN MY 20s
AND 30s.
MY MOM AND I WOULD GO TO
WESTGATE IN SAN FRANCISCO.
WE WOULD GO TO SAN MATEO.
YOU GET THE FREE SNACKS.
HICKORY FARMS.
THEN YOU GET SOME CANDY.
THEN YOU MIGHT GO TO NORDSTROM'S
BECAUSE THEY HAVE RESTAURANTS.
USUALLY AT THE TOP.
AND GET LOADED ON BLOODY MARY'S.
NEXT THING YOU KNOW, YOU PASS
OUT IN A MACY'S DRESSING ROOM,
NOT KNOWING WHERE YOU ARE.
SOMETIMES THEY HAVE REALLY WEIRD
BARS.
I REMEMBER A BAR IN HILLSDALE.
IT WAS UNDERGROUND AND SERVED
NOTHING BUT CRAPES.
I DON'T THINK IT LASTED.
THERE IS SOMETHING COOL ABOUT
SHOPPING WITH A BUZZ.
YOU DON'T GET -- INSTEAD YOU GET
ARROGANT, OBNOXIOUS.
YOU TURN INTO JESSE WATTERS, AS
OPPOSED TO -- BUT I WANT TO
TALK -- CAN I MENTION SOMETHING?
WHAT I NOTICE THAT IS VERY
STRESSFUL ABOUT THE HOLIDAYS IS
THE MEDIA.
CAN I TWIST THIS TOWARDS THE
MEDIA?
HAVE YOU NOTICED HOW ACTUAL NEWS
IS REDUCED BY LIKE 50 TO 70%?
AND IT IS BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO
PRESENT THE NEWS, THEY ARE GONE,
RIGHT?
PEOPLE GO AWAY.
THE HOSTS, PRODUCERS, SO WHAT
DOES IT TELL YOU WHEN THE
NEWSMAKERS ARE GONE AND THE NEWS
DISAPPEARS?
A LOT OF IT IS CREATED, AND WHAT
DO YOU HAVE TO DO?
YOU HAVE TO FILL UP THIS GIANT
HOLE WITH HYSTERICAL WEATHER
COVERAGE.
YOU ARE GOING TO DIE.
10 MILLION, 13 MILLION PEOPLE
WILL BE TRAVELING TOMORROW.
LET'S GO LIVE TO LaGUARDIA.
WELL, THERE IS A LINE RIGHT
HEAR, HEAR THE LINE IS GETTING
LARGER.
IS THAT FROM 2013?
I THINK THAT LOOKS LIKE 2013.
DON'T GET ME WRONG.
I'M ADDICTED TO THE WEATHER
COVERAGE.
WHEN IT'S ON, I CANNOT STOP
WATCHING IT.
BUT THE IMPACT, IS IT TOTALLY --
CAN WE PULL BACK A LITTLE BIT?
THAT'S ALL I'M SAYING?
>> Dana: I'VE GOT ONE MORE
THING ON MY SLEEVE.
WE ARE NOT DONE WITH THEIR
CHRISTMAS FUN.
HAVE YOU EVER HEARD OF THIS?
IT IS ALL THE RAGE NOW.
ALL YOU DO IS POUR PEPSI OVER
ICE, ADD SOME MILK, AND MIXED.
WE ARE GOING TO TRY THIS WITH
SOME OF AMERICA'S FAVORITE
COOKIES.
I MENTION DO YOU ARROGANT
PRODUCERS NOT REALIZE THAT THIS
IS WHAT LAVERNE AND SHIRLEY
DRANK?
PILK IS NOT NEW.
I HAVE NEVER HEARD IT BE CALLED
PILK.
BEFORE WE CALL IT SOMETHING
ELSE.
>> Dana: BE CAREFUL BECAUSE WE
DO NOT WANT TO HAVE A SPRAYING
SITUATION.
HAROLD IS NERVOUS, JESSE.
>> Jesse: WHY IS IT PEPSI?
>> Dana: BECAUSE IT IS PILK.
>> Greg: I'M NOT A BIG FAN.
TOO SWEET.
>> Katie: WHAT IS THE RATIO?
>> Dana: I DO NOT HAVE
INSTRUCTIONS.
>> Jesse: I AM GOING TO GO
MILK ON THE BASE.
>> Dana: YOU KNOW WHAT?
>> Jesse: SORRY, GUYS.
I CANNOT DRINK IT NOW.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW IF THIS
REMINDS ME OF?
EBONY AND IVORY.
THIS IS THE MOST DIVERSE DRINK,
COMING TOGETHER.
>> Dana: GIVE HIM THE MILK.
LET ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
JESSE, I THINK YOU SHOULD TRY
HERE IS --
>> Jesse: OH, COME ON.
>> Dana: READY?
>> Greg: I CANNOT PARTAKE,
UNFORTUNATELY.
>> Dana: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
LAVERNE WAS TALKING ABOUT.
I AM GOING TO START PUTTING AN L
ON MY SWEATER.
>> Katie: IT IS PRETTY GOOD.
>> Dana: SO WE HAVE SOME
COOKIES.
>> Greg: THEY ARE NEXT TO
HAROLD.
>> Jesse: I LIKE THESE.
THE CREAM --
>> Dana: IT LOOKS LIKE A CANDY
CANE ON TOP.
>> Jesse: THIS IS SHAPED LIKE
GINGERBREAD, BUT IS IT?
>> Dana: I WILL TRY THAT.
>> Jesse: THESE ARE GOOD.
>> Katie: THIS LOOKS LIKE A
PUMPKIN.
>> Dana: 18 DOZEN COOKIES --
>> Greg: YOU DIP IT IN THE
PILK.
I THINK IF YOU LOOK THAT UP ON
URBAN DICTIONARY, IT IS TOTALLY
DIFFEREN